- [Announcer] Shot clock is off.
Crowd comes to its feet.
The atmosphere in this place is electric.
- [Announcer] This building is shaking.
- [Announcer] It is deafening in here.
- [Announcer] Bogdanovic...up.
- [Announcer] Got it! It's over!
- [Announcer] What a scene.
- Man.
When the season halted.
Oh my goodness, bro, it hurt.
- Being in OKC, we got to witness
firsthand the postponing of the season,
and the fans are just left clueless.
And in that day, you kind of
felt the levity of the situation.
- That made a lot of sense to stop it, when we
didn't know much about what we were facing.
- With COVID, life paused.
Things changed.
The world stopped.
- When the season halted, it
was just like, OK, what next?
- I was disappointed, obviously, because as a
superfan, I look forward to going into TD Garden.
- [Snoop Dogg] I really do miss sports in general,
just watching the competition and whether
I'm at the arena or at home just missing.
- It's like you're on a high.
And all of a sudden the pandemic hits.
Man, you on a low again.
- All reports say the NBA is
inching closer to returning.
- I need you.
It's been sad.
It's been so sad and lonely without sports.
- Before the pandemic hit, oh my goodness, baby.
We was on our way.
- Just was feelin' good, like, you know,
we was set to, to really catch a groove.
- I just hope they're able to recapture some
of that going into the bubble in Orlando.
- My name is Darrell Bailey,
man, but y'all know me, baby.
Aka Clipper Darrell in the building, baby.
- My name is Nav Bhatia.
- My name is Garrett Haviland,
but you all know me as Thundor.
-This is Nasser Abasali, aka Aztec Gino.
- It's ya boy, big Snoop D.O. Double G.
King of the West Coast, representing the Lakers.
- I've been supporting the Thunder
since the very first season.
- Since my college days coming from the
beautiful islands of Trinidad and Tobago.
- When NBA arrived in Toronto, I fell in love,
and I've never missed a game for last 25 years.
- I decided, you know what?
I got a big gut.
Beautiful mural painting.
So why not go with it?
The very first painting was a jack-o'-lantern.
Deron Williams went to shoot
a technical free throw.
Ripped my shirt off and unveiled
the first Thundor belly art.
- Since the pandemic, man, what I've missed about
basketball is the comradery with the fans.
- We are like one big family.
When I go to the game, it's
my whole extended family.
- From a fan's perspective, it's
disappointing not to attend the games.
- But my players know that we are
going to be there in spirit.
- [Kyle Lowry] It's going to be different.
We know that they're supporting us no matter what.
- To know that I'm not going to be
there to cheer my guys on is going
to be just a complete mind explosion.
- I'm thinking about going to Orlando, man.
Just stand by the door.
Hopefully, somebody let me in.
- I don't think people understand how much
energy all the fans bring to the game.
- [Snoop Dogg] The way the crowd roars,
the adrenaline that you give is just a
certain feeling that can't be matched.
- [Aztec Gino] All of the superfans
is to make sure everyone who attends
a game enjoys the whole ambiance.
- [Kyle] Having their raw emotion, guys
can feed off of that energy, and it
kind of brings everything together.
- Not having fans in the building is
definitely gonna impact the players.
- [Thundor] When they go to shoot free throws, I
mean, who's going to be there to distract them?
- [Aztec Gino] The players are going to
miss feeding off the energy of the crowd.
- [Kyle] Just because you're not
there, don't mean you're forgotten.
We know that you're there.
We're gonna play hard for you guys.
- I just don't know, man.
I can't be there to cheer my guys.
Man, this hurts.
- [Thundor] When I get to go back to
a full arena, getting to see all the
familiar faces, my usher, Gaylord.
Like I know I'm going to have to
give that dude a big old bear hug.
- [Nav] When I go back to the arena,
I'm going to be back with my family.
- [Thundor] The high-fives, handshakes and hugs.
- [Aztec Gino] They all take photos with me.
You know, they like it when I do that.
- [Kyle] I can't wait to get
them back in our building.
- [Clipper Darrell] What I'm looking forward
to the most, man, seeing my 2020 L.A.
Clippers champions, baby, getting them rings.
- [Aztec Gino] I like their chances.
We have a great team.
- [Nav] We are the defending champions.
The first time, the world didn't believe us,
but they're going to prove them wrong again.
- Who can stop us, baby?
I'm telling you, man.
It's our time.
- Come on, Thunder.
I need you to rise up and dominate.
- We know you guys are still
there, and we appreciate you.
And we need you.
- You take care of the business in Orlando.
I take care of the business in Toronto.
- Stay safe.
- Stay healthy.
- Championship or nothing.
We gotta come back home with that thing.
- When I say L.A., you say Clippers.
L.A.!
- O-K-C.
O-K-C.
- Celtics.
No. 1
- Go, Raptors, go.